مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفاع الفرق بين ريال مدريد واي فريق اخر
انه ريال مدريد هو مثل الدوله العظمى اللي
لو صار في مشاكل عندها ب بالاسلحه
الموجوده لو كانت عم تحارب بمعركه وحست
انه راح تخسر عندها اسلحه حنا ويه قادره
دائما انها تستخدمها او على الاقل تهدد
فيها وهذا الوضع بالنسبه لريال مدريد ريال
مدريد مهما كان بوضع ضعف دفاعيا مثلا او
كان عنده مشكله باحد الخطوط دائما عنده
اللاعبين اللي عندهم الجوده العاليه اللي
مش موجوده عند الفريق الخصم واللي بيقدروا
يحسموا له المباريات ب لحظات بهجمه بكره
بفرصه بيخلصوا المباراه وبياخذ ريال مدريد
ثلاث نقاط وبتخلص الامور احد هذه الاسلحه
لا بل انه ابرز هذه الاسلحه هو اللاعب
الانجليزي والاستقدام المميز ويمكن افضل
صفقه صارت بالصيف الماضي وهو جود بلينغهام
جود بلينغهام اذا بدي ابدا بسرد ارقامه
ببدا مع اول رقم انه هو اول لاعب يسجل في
مباراتين بدوري ابطال اوروبا او في اول
مباراتين بدوري ابطال اوروبا لريال مدريد
منذ كريستيانو رونالدو عام 2009 مش بس هيك
جود بلينغهام صار مسجل ثمانيه اهداف مع
ريال مدريد وصانع ثلاثه اهداف في تسع
مباريات جود بلينغهام اخذ جائزه افضل لاعب
في المباراه سبع مرات باخر تسع مباريات
لعبها مع ريال مدريد معدل تسجيله مع
الريال هو هدف في كل
71.3 دقيقه مع الفريق الملكي ها الارقام
الفلكيه الى اسباب ونحن اليوم جايين نحكي
عن ه الاسباب شو اللي بخلي جود بلينغهام
حسب وجهه نظر كثيرين طبعا وانا منهم
يتوقعوا انه هذا اللاعب راح يجيب الكره
الذهبيه بالتاكيد والمساله مساله وقت فقط
الموضوع بيعتمد كله على فكره واحده بالثلث
الاخير بالملعب بلينغهام عنده قدره خارقه
على انه ياخذ القرار الصحيح بالثلث الاخير
وهذا امر غير معتاد بالنسبه للاعب عمره 20
سنه والدليل على هذا الكلام الهدفين اللي
تسجلوا على نابولي بالمباراه اللي اقيمت
يوم ثلاثاء على ارضيه ملعب ديجو ارماندو
مارادونا بالهدف الاول لنبه للهدف الاول
بلينغهام استغل طول قدمه وقطع الكره قطع
التمريره من مدافع نابولي وصار بموقف
الواحد على واحد مع المدافع الاخر وبهي
الحاله اي لاعب ممكن يفكر بانه ياخذ الكره
على اليمين ويسدد بالزاويه البعيده ولكن
بلينغهام لاحظ انه على يساره في فينيسيوس
جونيور اللي هو بوضع افضل من وضعه
واللاعبين بموقف اثنين على واحد على لاعب
ناق فمرر الكره بكل بساطه لفينيسيوس
فينيسيوس حطه بالجول 1-0 لريال مدريد
بالهدف الثاني بلينغهام وجد مساحه في
منتصف الملعب هاجم هذه المساحه وتقدم عد
من اللاعب الاول من نابولي او تخلص منه
اللي هو انجيزا وبعد ذلك عدى لاعب او
مدافع نابولي مستغلا ايضا طول قدميه
ومستغل قدرته على انه يغير وضعيه جسمه
ويتحرك بعكس اتجاه جسمه واللي هذا الامر
اللي بيخدع على المدافع وبيخليه يفكر انه
اللاعب رايح باتجاه واللاعب بوم بروح
بالاتجاه الاخر فراح بالاتجاه الاخر وسدد
كره بالزاويه البعيده ليسجل الهدف الثاني
لريال مدريد في المباراه هي القرارات
بتكون مصيريه جدا بالنسبه للاعبين لانه
اللاعب بياخذ القرار بجزء من الثاني
وبالتالي لما تكون قراراتك صح هذا امر بدل
على انه عندك ثقه عاليه بالنفس عندك قدرات
هائله بقدميك وعندك قراءه جيده جدا
لوضعيتها بالملعب احساس بالمكان وقراءه
لوضع اللاعبين لاعبي الخصم وهي طبعا وحده
من الميزات الرئيسيه لجود بلينغهام الميزه
الاخرى اللي عند بلينغهام هو قدرته على
الضغط العالي يعني هو لاعب بيعمل ضغط عالي
بشكل ممتاز جدا وهذا شفناه مثل ما حكينا
بالهدف الاول النقطه الاخرى ايضا هو توقعه
الجيد لمكان الكره شو يعني بعض المتابعين
والمحللين بقولوا انه والله بينغهام بسجل
اهدافه بالحظ انه هو واقف امام المرمى
وبيست انى الكره الثانيه وبيسجل هدف ولكن
على ارض الواقع ونحكي بصراحه ميزه الاحساس
بالمكان واحساسك بانه الكره رح تيجي بهذا
المكان هي مش متوفره عند كثير لاعبين في
قدره على التمركز بالمكان المناسب وهي
ميزه بيمتاز فيها صلاح وبيم تز فيها
بلينغهام انهم بمركزه باماكن عارفين انه
الكره رح تجي بهذا المكان وبالتالي بيكون
موجود بالمكان المناسب وبيسجل هدف الاكس
جي تبع اهداف بلينغهام لحد الان او
الاهداف المتوقعه هي 4.5 يعني هو مسجل من
مسافات قريبه ولكن على ارض الواقع تمركز
هو اللي بيحكم تسجيلك لهذه الاهداف
وبالتالي هذا امر مش سهل والا كانوا كل
اللاعبين عملوه النقطه الاخرى الموجوده
عند بلينغهام هي قدرته وقدراته ومهاراته
شو يعني اللاعب مش سريع يعني هو مش من
اللاعبين السريعين لا هو لاعب ما عنده
سرعه ولكنه لاعب قادر انه يحمي كرته بجسمه
بشكل مناسب جدا وقادر انه يستغل مهارته
ويوظفها بخدمه الفريق الفرق بين اللاعب
المهاري واللاعب المهاري اللي بيخدم
الفريق كثير كبير لما اللاعب بون عنده
مهاره مثل نيمار مثلا مثل بعض اللاعبين
دينيلسون سابقا كان عنده مهارات كثيره
ولكن ما ووظفوا ه المهاره بخدمه الفريق
وظفوها بالاستعراض وبخد انفسهم بينما لاعب
مثل بلينغهام ووظف كل مهارته بخدمه الفريق
وهذا امر بذكرني بشكل كبير بزين الدين
زيدان زيدان اللي كان ممتاز به العمليه
انه يوظف مهارته لخدمه الفريق ولم يكن
سريعا ايضا مثل بلينغهام وبالتالي هن
الاثنين متشابهين ربما بالبروفايل لهيك
الناس بتشبهن ببعض عداك عن انه الاثنين
رقمهم خمسه مع ريال مدريد طبعا بلينغهام
مع الوقت حسب رؤيته الشخصيه ظل بهال
الشخصيه وبالمستوى راح يجيب الكره الذهبيه
رح يكون افضل لاعب في العالم وبينغ هام
اوريدي هذا الموسم قدر يسد مكان بنزيما
وقدر انه يقود خط وسط ريال مدريد بتسع
مباريات الماضيه واعتقد انه على مدار
الموسم اداؤه را يروح بشكل تصاعدي ورح
نشوف منه اداء افضل من هيك بعد لحتى يوصل
للقمه ويصل لمراحل خارقه مع ريال مدريد
هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم بعد الصافره
حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف
خير